>>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST
GAVE A LAST-MINUTE BOOST TO MAGA
REPUBLICANS AND DIRECTED NEARLY
$3 MILLION IN AD SPENDING FOR
CANDIDATES IN PENNSYLVANIA,
ARIZONA AND GEORGIA.
THAT COMES AHEAD OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TRIP TO FLORIDA,
WHERE HE AND GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
WILL HOLD DUELING RALLY EVENTS.
JOINING US NOW IS -- OLIVA,
LET'S START WITH YOU.
THERE'S A POTENTIAL FIGHT
BETWEEN TRUMP AND DeSANTIS, BUT
IT'S INTERESTED THAT YOUR FORMER
BOSS POSTED THIS ON TO HIS
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT, TALKING ABOUT
THE LATEST DIVISION, I GUESS,
AND RIFTS BETWEEN HIM AND HIS
FORMER BOSS.
LET'S PLAY IT.
>> I WAS ALWAYS LOYAL TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WAS MY PRESIDENT AND WAS MY
FRIEND, WE WORKED CLOSE TOGETHER
AND FORGED A CLOSE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP, BUT IN THE END
CAME ON DIFFICULT TIMES.
>> THAT IS PART OF HIS BOOK
PROMOTION, BUT OLIVIA, IS
THAT -- THERE PERHAPS SOMETHING
BIGGER?
>> I CAN'T PREDICT THE FUTURE,
BUT I CERTAINLY BELIEVE HE DOES
INTEND TO RUN, HE'S STILL IN THE
RUNNING, AND CAN TOUT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY DID, BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
SEPARATED THEM -- DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT MIKE PENCE DID.
HE HAD THE COURAGE TO ACTUALLY
DO THE MIGHT THING THAT DAY.
WE HAD DeSANTIS AND TRUMP I
THINK BETWEEN THE THREE OF THEM,
MIKE PENCE IS THE
DIFFERENTIATOR.
YOU CAN'T OVERSTATE THE DIVIDE
BETWEEN NOT ONLY THESE TWO
PARTIES, BUT THESE TWO PARTY
LEADERS.
DONALD TRUMP IS SUPPORTING THE
MAGA REPUBLICANS, AND A LOT OF
THEM ELECTION DENIERS, AND YOU
HAVE PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAKING TO
THE NEED TO PRESERVE DEMOCRACY,
WHAT DOES PRESIDENT BIDEN NEED
TO SAY TONIGHT, AND WHO DIRECTLY
DOES HE NEED TO BE ADDRESSING?
>> I HOPE IT'S AN INCLUSIVE
MESSAGE.
I HOPE IT'S A MESSAGE THAT'S
AIMED AT BRINGING IN REPUBLICANS
THAT'S NOT AMONG THE 30% OF
REPUBLICANS.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE ON
THE MARGINS WHO WILL GO OAT TO
VOTE NEXT TUESDAY, WHO MAY NOT
BE VOTING FOR DEMOCRATS, BOND
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT HAVE
TAKING HOLD IN MY PARTY.
MY ONE CAUTION IS THIS -- I
DON'T EXPECT TO HEAR IT IN
REMARKS, BUT DEMOCRATS MADE A
STRATEGIC ERROR WHEN THEY PUT
ABOUT $50 MILLION BEHIND
ELECTION DENIERS, TO BOOST
CANDIDATES THEY THOUGHT WOULD BE
EASIER FOR DEMOCRATS TO BEAT,
BUT SOME OF THOSE MAY WIN.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE BIDEN
CONDEMN THAT.
I DON'T EXPECT TO SEE THAT, BUT
THAT GIVES MORE CREDENCE TO HIS
PUSH FOR WE ALL HAVE A STAKE IN
THIS DEMOCRACY AND A ROLE TO
PLAY.
>> AND OLIVIA, NEXT WEEK'S
ELECTIONS RESULTS COULD TAKE
DAYS TO BE FINALIZED.
OF COURSE GIVEN THE ELECTION
DENIERS, THAT OPENS THE
OPPORTUNITY ADD THE FLOODGATES
TO SAY THESE WERE NOT FAIR.
IS THAT ENOUGH?
WHAT MORE CAN THE PRESIDENT DO
AND DID SENSIBLE REPUBLICANS DO
TO REMIND AMERICANS THIS IS JUST
HOW THE PROCESS WORKS, AND WE
MAY NOT SEE THE RESULTS RIGHT
AWAY?
, WELL, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR HIM TO TALK ABOUT IT, AND
STRESS THE FACT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE DAYS TO FIGURE OUT THE
RESULTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT, BECAUSE THAT
DOESN'T GIVE AIR PLAY TO THE
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS OUT THERE,
SHOULD IT NOT GO THE WAY THEY
WANT IT TO GO.
I HOPE HE TALKS ABOUT THE NEED
TO REALLY TAMP DOWN POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, AND HOW CRITICAL THAT
IS.
I THINK REPUBLICANS ARE ACTUALLY
MESSENGERS FOR THAT.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT NEED TO BE
OUT THERE SAKE THIS COULD TAKE
TIME.
THEY HAVE WEATHER STARTED TO
CIRCULATE THAT, AND QUITE
FRANKLY, I WORRY I WORRY
>> I WAS TALKING ABOUT OUR
CHILDREN, AND WHY THEY DON'T
HAVE BETTER SECURITY, I SAID OUR
POLITICIANS HAVE SECURITY, AND
WE NEED TO HAVE SECURITY FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE TAPE.
DON'T DO ANY CREATIVE EDITING
LIKE THE FAKE MEDIA ATTEMPTS TO
DO, AND YOU'LL SEE WHAT I'M
SAYING.
>> PLAN IT IN YOUR BUDGET TO
INCREASE SCHOOL SAFETY AND HOW
SO?
>> AND LEAD WITH THE LAST
BUDGET.
IT WAS ABOUT 50 MILLION PUT INTO
INCREASING SCHOOL SAFETY, WITH
SCHOOL -- SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS, ARMED OFFICERS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE PROTECTING OUR KIDS.
IT IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO PROTECT
OUR KIDS AT SCHOOL.
THEY ACT LIKE IT IS.
NANCY PELOSI, WELL, SHE'S GOT
PROTECTION WHEN SHE'S --
APPARENTLY HER HOUSE DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF PROTECTION --
[ LAUGHTER ]
-- BUT IF ALL LAWMAKERS HAVE
PROTECTION, IF OUR LAWMAKERS CAN
HAVE PROTECTION, IF OUR
POLITICIANS CAN HAVE PROTECTION,
OUR ATHLETES, CERTAINLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN OUR LIVES,
OUR CHILDREN, SHOULD HAVE
PROTECTION.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE FOUND
FUNNY THERE.
I DON'T KNOW THE AUDIENCE FOUND
FUNNY, BUT WILL --
>> I THINK SHE'S GOING TO WIN,
AND I THINK THAT'S PARTLY DUE TO
KATIE HOBBS NOT RUNNING WELL
AGAINST HER.
SHE'S SOMEONE WHO I BELIEVE
KNOWS BETTER.
SHE'S A LONGTIME JOURNALIST IN
PHOENIX, A CREDIBLE PERSON UNTIL
SHE STARTED NOT ONLY AUDITIONING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S RACE, BUT
ANGLING SO I THINK EVERYBODY
SHE'S DOING MAY